previously on Eris we looked at how to
use feature activations for
understanding neural networks how can we
extend these ideas further and get even
more out of these methods stay tuned to
find out
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to
extend the ideas of feature activations
in convolutional neural networks even
further by applying them to entire
images to create activation grids and
then see how we can use that to produce
an activation atlas this video picks up
where the previous video left off so if
you haven't watched that you should
definitely check it out first
now previously we looked at how the
neurons in and convolutional neural
networks the layers can be organized
into channels and then stacked like a
layer cake we can also organize it in
our mind vertically so that we are
looking at a certain patch of that layer
and consider the activation of all
neurons stack together over a region we
call this spatial activations spatial
activations give us a sense of what
features a specific region of an image
is activating most strongly by doing
this across all the different patches of
an image we can build an activation grid
showing us the features that are
activating the strongest for each region
this is for only one particular layer so
now we want to repeat this process for
the other layers some earlier in the
network and some later earlier layers
like mix 3a they show us the edges and
patterns that still mildly resemble the
original image while later layers are
much more identifiable as the animal
body parts that are being recognized in
that part of image now activations are
they're just numbers right and so some
activations they can be larger than
others so what we can now do is scale
the size of each of these grids to the
size of the active
so that'll give us a sense of the
importance of a given region of the
image to that layer based on how
strongly the network is activating so
now we can see which regions are most
strongly activated per layer and how
these activations are propagating
through each layer of the network now
this gives us a sense of the salience of
the different parts of the image
activation grids tell us about some of
the activations of the neural network
for a specific image but what about all
the other activations of the network how
might we understand the other types of
activations well we need to feed in lots
of example images of all sorts of types
so what if we did that we could run lots
of images in fact we could run a million
different example images through the
network and record all of their
activation words all these individual
activations correspond to some and a
higher dimensional location in the
neural networks activation space so to
speak and if we position our activations
each of these sub grids into their
respective locations in this higher
dimensional space we now have for our 1
million example images broken up and
scattered across this landscape
unfortunately high dimensional spaces
are well they're tough for us to
visualize so we can project this space
down to two dimensions but there's still
the problem having just millions of
activations that deal with ray so that's
rather unwieldy for visualizing so let's
draw a grid over the whole 2d projection
and we'll take for each grid the average
of the activations within it this won't
cause us to lose too much detail since
activations that are close together
they're similar to one another so now we
can finally resize each grid based on
the number of activations on that grid
giving us a sense of how strongly the
network responds to that particular type
of input now we can repeat this entire
process for a couple different layers
put it into a nice web interface and you
and activation atlas so let's explore it
and see what it looks like to navigate
through this space if we start our
journey in the top area of the lair
mixed 4c there appears to be kind of a
variety of dog phases then as we go down
things shift to showing kind of the
backs of four-legged animals and then we
keep going we get to some legs and feet
merging into the ground and ground
related things and that slowly
transitions into kind of sandy surfaces
and some water there's lots of
interesting pets through the activation
atlas and it's really neat I think that
the images shown you know they smoothly
transition from one region to the next
we can also look at a specific class
activations in the Atlas so we can
filter it out and just look at one
particular class let's say a great white
shark I like to start with the bottom
most layer mixed 5b since that's going
to show images that are most similar to
kind of the final prediction so we can
really recognize what it is we're seeing
it's meaningful we see some regions we'd
expect you know various fish like
imagery and over here there's some water
related imagery right and what's what's
this over here
yeah that is that a baseball what is a
baseball doing so late in the network
structure so if the network thinks that
baseball's have a pretty strong
relationship to well great white sharks
what would happen then perhaps if we add
in an image of a baseball just slapped
it on top of this image of a grey whale
could we fool our own Network into
thinking that it's seeing a great white
shark at first it doesn't quite work but
with a bit of fiddling around with the
image size we can get the network to
output great white shark has its top
prediction for the image this is pretty
fun and you can look for all sorts of
other oddities I also found in the mixed
5 B layer for a great white shark that
airship is another kind of unusual label
associated with great white sharks so I
try to do something similar I went on
and found some images of airships and
tinkered around with the sizing and
position of the airship image and I
found that I could eventually convince
the model that it was a great white or
in some cases a killer whale depending
on the airship I use and where I put it
so you should try this out and be sure
to share what kinds of funny predictions
you got the model to make in the
comments down below
neural networks are generally opaque but
with tools like an activation Alice at
your disposal you can get a better
understanding of how they work and
expose some of the weaknesses that might
be present I'm excited about the
possibility of how these approaches will
be extended in the future as well as
it's applications to other types of
models as well thanks for watching this
episode of cloud AI adventures and if
you enjoyed it please like and subscribe
to get all the latest episodes right
when they come out for now check out
activation analysis and see if you can
find something interesting in the
relationships between the different data
classes
[Music]